Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us!
Thank you!
Are you making fun of me?
Huh?
I am.
You're welcome.
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for our 42nd episode today!
BAU BAU!
What?
Spit it out!
I see a number of new Ruffians.
Thank you new Ruffians and thank you all Ruffians.
Just for them.
Not all Ruffians.
Is that how it is?
Just for the new Ruffians.
I'll explain what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
Old Ruffians, don't complain.
You know what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
Close your ears, okay?
Close your ears!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Not the left paw.
Right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you awake?
I'm awake.
You were asking me, huh?
I wasn't.
I was asking the Ruffians, but thank you for your input.
Ruffians, did you see Pero by any chance?
Yeah, again.
I think there was another Pero Sighting.
This time he is... De-den!
This picture has impact!
Wait, was your train being delayed by Pero?
That's not very nice of him.
But, Moco-chan, I have a feeling you know that maybe it wasn't Pero's idea to get tied up and find an inconvenient place to lay down for a nap.
Why?
What do you think, Ruffians?
It's okay, Pero can still fly, but what if he's tied up like this?
He can't fly.
His rope is binding him.
I don't know.
I guess maybe it could be that he wanted to get up and close to the train.
You know, it does look like a very classic train with all that steam and smoke.
True, true.
I think maybe he's just being a bit... He's being a bit silly.
He's just being a bit dramatic, you know.
Silly?
If you look closely, the train isn't even moving, okay?
True.
He's not in harm's way.
He's fine.
I guess.
Yeah, he just wanted to see it close.
But I think it'd be really cool to go on a ride on this train, you know?
I wonder what it'd feel like, what it'd smell like.
You could probably smell the ancestors coming from it, right?
All the perfume.
Interesting experience.
Sorry about Pero getting in the way there.
But did anyone untie him in the end?
We'll have to see if maybe Pero's gonna be here again next week.
Maybe?
BAU BAU!
Hopefully not.
He's good.
I don't know.
I'm a little bit concerned.
Maybe that's the end of the Pero Sighting corner?
He's good.
But we have happy news!
Happy news!
Wow, Ruffians.
You remember what happened at the end of October, right?
A lot of stuff happened at the end of October, but... I did.
Maybe it's not fair to ask that question.
Wow.
At the end of October, FUWAMOCO!
We uploaded our second cover song, "Cute na Kanojo"!
Ruffians, you had a look, right?
I listened.
I think you did.
You used your ears for that.
Thank you so much for the warm reception despite, you know, it being a little bit of a creepy song.
Thanks to you Ruffians, it now has over 250k views!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians!
It really makes us happy that you enjoy our singing and our music so much!
We can't wait to record even more songs!
Despite sometimes how tricky and time consuming it can be.
It's a surprise for us and for you!
We couldn't do our best.
You know we want to be able to show you the Twin Guard Dog idols FUWAMOCO too, right?
And you know, lots of different sides to us as well.
So we'll continue to do our best!
This is the sound an idol makes, right?
Right!
You know you're a true idol when you can make that sound, okay?
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
It sounds like a drill.
Exactly.
We're the Twin Guard Dog Drills.
That's strong.
Nobody can stop our drill!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
When we record the cover songs, I promise it won't have any of those sounds in it, okay?
I guess.
But is that what the Ruffians want?
Is that what the Ruffians want?
What if they want the drill sounds?
Maybe.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Do your best power washing sound.
3, 2, 1!
What's this power washing sound like?
It has to have more of a water sound, Moco-chan.
That's not very violent.
That's like a fountain.
I don't know it.
What does power washing sound like?
I'll have to ask Pony-senpai.
We have to study a little bit.
BAU BAU!
Please look forward to it.
Whatever song we have next that doesn't have drilling in it.
Or power washing.
BAU BAU!
Well, there's more FUWAMOCO news!
Ruffians!
Did you happen to not get much sleep?
What type of question is that, huh?
Well, maybe your morning has also been connected to night time.
You might know what we're gonna mention, huh?
Poruru-oneechan celebrated her 3rd anniversary with a 3D Live!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations, Poruru-oneechan!
Were you able to watch Ruffians?
You didn't sleep much.
FUWAMOCO, we were going to try in real time, but we just had to get some sleep.
We tried though.
We tried to do homework and stay up, but uh-uh.
BAU BAU.
But if you did, you might have noticed a song that we also recently sung during one of our walk-in-room parties.
Did you notice?
Kurenai!
BAU BAU!
It was a really fun performance, so make sure you check it out.
K-Ruffians!
We also really enjoyed her original song, Persona, as well as the collab for Summer Night Time with Aki-senpai and Ren-senpai!
I felt their voices worked so well for it.
We really really enjoyed her last song, the Nanto Sekai Kou ni Hikikomori!
Hikikomori, I kind of messed up.
Right!
Dampakumi.
And it worked really well for you!
It's a strong voice and high energy too!
Right, it was perfect.
It's always such a treat, FWN3D.
Please check it out all three of them, even if you couldn't check it live.
You know, you can still watch the archive, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Happy 3rd Anniversary, FWN3D!
BAU BAU!
That was good.
I wish we could've stayed up.
BAU BAU.
We did our best.
Not quite enough.
Wow, Ruffians.
Guess what!
I actually wanted to kill the Ruffians.
Guess it!
Now you're making demands of them this early in the morning.
I am.
There's been... There's been... No!
No misunderstandings.
Why, Moco-chan?
YOU MISUNDERSTANDING!
I'm scared.
BAU BAU!
Why is it that you always get sad, Ruffians?
It's a good thing.
Why?
You know, we... FUWAMOCO, we're always saying silly things by accident.
They get misunderstood.
It's a bad trait of ours.
I know.
Really?
Don't ever mean to say weird things, okay?
We were on purpose.
Don't misunderstand, okay?
Yeah, but... You understand, right?
Moco-chan, after three months... Maybe we're getting better.
Maybe.
What do you think?
Are we getting better?
What?
Is it more that we're just getting better at forgetting them?
Forgetting them or just not noticing them?
Maybe not forgetting them, but just conveniently avoiding them.
Conveniently avoiding them, maybe?
You're getting better at forgetting!
Getting worse at noticing them.
You're getting used to them.
Maybe.
Maybe that's the truth.
I don't think it's the truth.
You've become excellent forgetters.
I think that's a good treat.
Forgetting?
Really?
Sometimes.
In this case.
I prefer to remember every moment with the Ruffians, but... True.
But this is okay to forget.
This one, yeah.
It's better for you.
Yeah.
You don't know!
I don't know.
I'm getting fluffier.
Does that mean I'm getting fuzzier?
You don't mean like fluffier and the getting fluffier for winter kind of way, do you?
Do you?!
It's important to not misunderstand.
Don't misunderstand.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Good job, FUWAMOCO.
It's what you're supposed to say now, okay, Ruffians?
Just so you know.
Well, Ruffians, you know... We all know that this weekend, this upcoming weekend, it's going to be a little different than most, you know.
FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be focusing on getting some important homework done.
Which means, you know...
It'll be a little strange since we won't be able to see each other for quite a while.
A weekend, right?
A couple days.
Maybe.
Maybe!
But, but, you know, we thought... We thought because it might be a little rough...
We do a Twitterspace!
BAU BAU!
A Twitterspace, another Twitterspace.
Our second Twitterspace.
Good!
Especially since things might be getting a bit messy again.
We'll chit-chat together while tidying up all the fluff and fries, okay?
That means you have to too.
This base will happen on Sunday the 12th at 1pm PT and 6am JST.
That'll be the 13th JST.
We'll be looking at your comments in the live chat that will open temporarily on YouTube.
Yeah, on YouTube, by following FUWAMOCO Morning.
So, FUWAMOCO Morning's live chat will open for a bit.
For a bit, and then it'll go goodbye for a little while.
We hope that you'll join us for a bit more time that we can spend together.
After that, we'll go straight back to our homework.
Straight back to it, yeah.
Got it.
So early!
It's a little bit early, but you know, that way, you know, the day is still kind of...
In the swing of things!
And I'll be all tiny!
No, I'll be FINE!
There it is.
Oh my gosh, that's the hundredth sneeze.
I don't know how to feel right now.
Congratulations, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
The 42nd FUWAMOCO Morning and the private sneeze!
I wasn't expecting to sneeze today.
You have to ask me for my commentary, okay?
Moco-chan, how does it feel to sneeze 100 times within 3 months?
Well, I feel like now I'm so famous, everyone noses me for my sneezing.
And now I'm very famous, well known for my sneezing.
Although it seems, Ruffians, that all those sneezes have gone to her head.
It's gone to my head!
They've gone to my sinuses!
Everyone noses me from my sinuses!
Yes.
Well, Moco-chan, do you have any ideas for, you know, maybe a tissue line?
Or a nasal spray?
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for your messages.
For the contacts.
Okay.
You can, you can phone us at the hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Yeah, yeah!
Phone us at the hashtag, okay?
I can, I can do that stuff.
I can say this is amazing.
Yeah.
So make sure to show the tissues are the strongest ever tissues.
Strongest tissues!
Nothing can break them!
Smell like roses!
Cute patterns!
Little dogs!
Rather than smelling like roses, it'd be better if they're Mococo-scented, no?
Are you saying that roses don't smell like me?
I guess I'll have to take a good smell later, huh?
We are celebrating!
Thank you, number one sneezing Moco-chan!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for the main voice!
BAU BAU!
I think that I will likely continue my sneeze record whether I want to or not.
We look forward to it, Moco-chan.
We look forward to it.
Do you.
Now continuing with FUWAMOCO Morning!
Back to regular programming.
I'm sorry for the interruption.
It was a very important news update.
Live news breaking right now, sneezing into your heart.
Yes.
Sneezing into your heart.
Beautiful, beautiful Moco-chan here.
We're all Ruffians!
We hope that you'll join us for a new interface on Sunday the 12th at 1pm PT.
That way we can all kind of tidy up the fluff and the fuzz.
You know?
And maybe, maybe Moco-chan will sneeze too.
Likely.
Thank you!
Moco-chan!
You gave the Ruffians some homework doing your Pup Talk on Wednesday, right?
I did, but it wasn't that serious.
Well, maybe Ruffians, you know what?
Maybe one day you just couldn't wake up in time doing Moco-chan's Pup Talk.
And if you weren't able to get your homework done yet, you still can!
There's no dead one.
You could even do it over and over if you wanted to.
It made us really happy.
Thank you, Ruffians!
But you know, we know that life is busy, it's rough too.
So I don't think Moco-chan, you won't be giving any more homework from here on, right?
You can't copy, you have to do your own homework, okay?
You have to, yeah.
But yeah, we're sure you know, but we also have our own homework to get done!
And we're gonna do our best to get it done to the best we can!
And as quickly as we can.
And quickly.
Yeah.
Not perfect.
Just done.
Done, you know.
We'll do it for you, Ruffians, but also ourselves too, you know.
And that's what's important, you know.
That way, we can all enjoy a bunch of really cool things together!
Let's do it, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, this month's theme is balance, so we're trying to get some more balance into FWM and get it closer to the golden time of 20 minutes long.
So let's go straight to our regular corners, Moco-chan!
Okay!
We have a Doggie of the Day.
Today we have...
Kalani as Doggie of the Day!
Great shape.
She enjoys sunbathing and patrolling the neighborhood to chase down the postal worker.
Very diligent.
Hardworking.
Double cute!
She looks like she's taking such a good nap.
We'll be careful not to look too closely or we'll all start feeling sleepy again, right?
This is FUWAMOCO Morning.
Not FUWAMOCO Nap.
Okay.
Is it okay if I just kinda cuddle up right around your neck there?
I love the paw pillow.
The paw pillow, right?
How does Kalani BAU BAU?
I think it has to be pretty scary and big.
You know, to scare off the postal workers.
Pretty traditional. Well, you know...
Today, this month, the theme is balance and it's Kalani!
Kalani enjoys a pretty balanced life, you know?
Naps, sunbathing, chasing off strange postal records.
It's important, you know?
It's sleep, relaxation, exercise.
Right, it's the best doggy life one could wish for, right?
Exactly!
You know, especially so close beside an owner who loves her just as much as she loves them.
Kalani has the idea.
Of course.
I can't help but be a bit envious, right?
You know, Moco-chan, we have an important duty.
Important job.
Yeah, to protect every Ruffian smile.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Did you really take this?
It's so fluffy.
It's so fuzzy.
It's so beautiful.
It's not fair.
The first thing I thought is that I want to play hide-and-go-seek in them.
You know, it's just so fuzzy here.
Would you come look for us?
Even if you're allergic.
Even if.
Even if you sneeze a lot, would you come look for us?
Why is it so beautiful though?
I've never quite seen a sight like this in the Northwest.
Right!
I want to see them all blow in the wind.
Cute.
Oh, you think about it, Moco-chan.
We're kind of the pampas grass color too, right?
Maybe.
We'll be blending in good.
It looks the same.
Thank you for sharing this with us today!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, fuzzy grass, right?
It's mine.
So pretty.
And for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
FUWAMOCO have hinted before that the reason you work so hard is because of how hungry you are.
Where does our hunger come from?
How do you say hungry?
Stay hungry.
I said stay hungry.
How do you say hungry?
Where does our hunger come from?
Good question.
Probably passion.
Foolishness.
And pain.
Probably.
I don't know, we're used to being told no on things.
But we think an important part of the journey overall, and like our creative process, is to try to figure out how we can change that no into yes.
I know.
Sometimes it's just not possible, but...
Why not try?
Right!
Yeah, we understand, you know, that we're rather silly for being this hungry, and maybe it doesn't make sense at times.
Maybe we'd be better, maybe easier if we weren't this hungry.
But what is with the pondering?
We can't help it, Ruffians!
We are!
You know, we make it difficult for ourselves too, and we understand this as well.
Yeah, we could make it easier.
But we don't.
Also, guard dog training was really hard on us, so sometimes it was even painful.
So, it's that pain that keeps us driven to go forward too.
Cuz you know, if we give up now, then those painful memories will just continue to stay that.
If we continue, there could be more pain.
But if we give up, I feel like that would just hurt even more, right?
So we continue!
Because we're not done.
Our hunger just grows!
Multiplies!
BAU BAU!
Probably not.
But it's okay.
But that's who FUWAMOCO is, right?
It could be easier.
We don't want to make it easier.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
Please continue to submit your Doggy of the Days, you know, your questions, your Pero Sightings, your walks, even though it's cold.
And don't forget to use the hashtag
FWMC Morning oki!
Now for our next stream!
We have... Well, we have a very comfy evening tonight because all together with Abbot, we're gonna be having a movie night!
Yeah!
Watch it all!
Over on Nerissa's channel, we're watching her movie pick this month.
It's the Princess and the Pauper Barbie movie.
The Pauper.
Princess and the Pauper Barbie Movie.
It's hard to say.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO, we've never seen a Barbie movie before, so we're not too sure what to expect.
But Nerissa really likes it!
And we really like Nerissa!
So we're looking forward to it!
But we hope you'll join us, Ruffians!
Don't forget, right?
The Princess and the Pauper.
No, the Pauper.
BAU BAU!
If we take another peek at our schedule, you'll see, you know, this weekend's a little bit different.
It's a bit different.
But, you know, we're going to focus really hard on our homework.
Hopefully we can get through most of it.
If not all of it, hopefully quite a bit though.
I really hope we got it, can I still do it?
But we'll also be there for the rebroadcasting of our Unarmed Archive Karaoke from our debut month.
Our debut month, that was quite a while ago.
We hope you'll be there for it, Ruffians.
And we'll also be sharing our new schedule afterwards, so we think you should be there for it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for our second FWMCM!
And the 100th sneeze!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Madorokai!
BAU BAU!
Chrysalis!
Lemuel!
BAU BAU!
Tanuki!
Hades!
BAU BAU!
Substitute!
World Class!
BAU BAU!
Sumi!
Mace!
BAU BAU!
Corporate Chief!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!